boy sweetie cat but I'm just gonna leave
that in the beginning in the video on
but there it is
I swear to god she knows yeah she knows
she doesn't want you know attention take
it away from her
yeah I've noticed a lot of other a lot
of other content creators have the same
damn problem every time they start
talking the cats get in the way woof
what are you doing pull the cameras down
yeah [ __ ] when the camera it was
actually the light yeah like I said a
lot of the some of the channels I
watched like Dominic Noble and stuff
like that he'll actually put because he
does it in front of a green screen green
screen and then at the end he'll put
like all the you know where he messed up
and stuff and it's usually like when one
of the cats like climbs in cuz he s -
yeah like climate like Church started
climb up his leg or like me our
something like backs he's not paying
attention it's like really funny Rob Rob
Levinson is like streaming from a live
haunted house somewhere the parent house
yeah well he said he he was on the way
there right now with um you know at
while we're recording this which is
dirty but he's so he should be there
about four o'clock and I guess he's
doing a live feed from there yeah um so
I might have that on like in the
background while I'm working online yeah
he's done watch it watch it not gonna do
it man we work we create content - well
I can have I can have it on on my other
computer I just had I had some actual
design work I had to do today yeah and
stuff like that I'm just gonna slowly it
is going slowly cut so I don't know why
it's just some days I have a thing where
it's hard for me to like think of a
concept and I'm just like I feel like
I'm rushed cuz I have like other stuff I
got to do but you know um I don't think
so probably not I don't have anything in
like particular I'm just watching
schools go crazy yeah yeah just watch it
fools go crazy man okay over the over
the pandemic I'm not worried about
you're not worried about I'm not worried
about it either they're worried about it
but you know I've made my comments
already on this I just I think it's
overblown I don't think it's overblown
I'm just saying that there's nothing
that I can do about it so I can't worry
about it the numbers don't add up I got
to do what I got to do it just looks
real suspicious the numbers don't add up
I know just gonna say some it's you know
I'm wondering if China faked it and
faked it I mean like maybe it's a real
virus I'm saying that but more if they
faked their own casualty figures I doubt
it
so it was as small as they say they were
I'm just saying it's like I don't not
everything's like a conspiracy or fake
or everything like that I know that's
very a lot of people think that nowadays
I think it was released on purpose no I
don't think it was but um yeah so what
did we okay so last night we watched
we've rented a couple of new movies that
we will be reviewing for the matinee
show both more so well one of them we
didn't finish because I fell asleep
because I was [ __ ] exhausted because
I'd been up since 6:30 so we have to
watch the rest of it tonight
they're both seem pretty decent though I
have to say you know no media I thought
the two that we saw yeah well we're only
half down with a second one yeah I mean
I don't want to go too much into them
because we're gonna be talking about him
on the matinee the second one though the
Irish would have started to bog down you
fell asleep in it
well yeah cuz I'm really really tired
I'm like okay I know there's a monster
but where the [ __ ] is it you know I mean
they're too much suspense and not enough
showing it to me so although we were
kind of drunk to say yeah I'm gonna look
at it again yeah well like I said it was
well-made I mean it looked good
the acting was good yeah I was into it I
just couldn't stay awake anymore cuz I
was like really really tired what kind
of monster is this it's about time to
show us the monster and tell us how it
works
yeah you know because I I don't want to
get into like I said we still got a
review they're trying to be like alien 1
yeah nothing wrong with that
yeah and it was kind of working but by
now you know I mean it should have been
something kind of major should have
happened yeah but I
didn't really see anything major having
sex started to stall kind of like that
um that [ __ ] Australia one that we
were watching that it was good for about
20 minutes and it just felt we were read
that one on the next day on the last
Matt nation yeah boy has a waist yeah it
could have got a lot better
oh well what are you gonna do but yeah
so those are the ones that are gonna be
coming up later this week um let's see
the show about black month of black monk
of Pontefract and the brother brother
dolly case like the poltergeist cases
that one up earlier today uh three hours
so I hope you guys are enjoying that I
just got a message from somebody that
lives in Pontefract that listen star
show so they said hey if you want me to
send pictures of the house I can do that
because it's like right by my [ __ ]
house but yeah they said you guys are
legends for doing that so I thank you
very much like I said we hadn't done a
paranormal one and so long and
apparently some people really appreciate
those so I guess I'll have to integrate
more paranormal cases like endure
upcoming John the man and paranormal for
me it's a little more lightheaded a
little more fun well yeah it is it is a
lot more fun not as a downer he asked me
I mean I do like doing the true crime
shows like I said and that's mostly what
I get requests for but it I guess it is
good to like not have just a constant
parade of like grim talk also oddities
yeah cuz there's probably a few and like
you said you know we might do something
about like as old-school like strongmen
and stuff like that cuz that's probably
I found that kind of interesting like
yeah they had a lot of impact on society
yeah oh yeah and you've told me
something about it like when we were out
walking and stuff like that and I think
that would probably make a good show I
mean everybody seemed to like the
[ __ ] oh one and the one about Steven
Seagal and yeah that kind of stuff so I
feel like it'll be kind of similar to
that well nothing is that eventually we
could focus in on certain kind of
martial arts on a specific one or you
know cuz I I believe a lot of that
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah well might be a
good show yeah I'd say you know we'll
see what they say there's just like I
said I don't think we're ever gonna run
out of topics now cuz we never run out
of topics for this [ __ ] show and we
didn't even play on we're gonna talk
we just kind of like sit in here and be
like when we first started the show we
thought we would run out of content we
thought we would run out of stuff that
funny we wrote down all the [ __ ]
topics we wanted to do well sometimes
like I would like remember somebody
first start with we were like well we
got about 80 of them yeah and then we
couldn't think of anything else now it
just keeps multiplying yeah it's like
I've had [ __ ] that like that I thought
of like [ __ ] three years ago and that
would still have to because people keep
like requesting stuff and everything
yeah but uh yeah so do you want to like
wrap this up yeah because we got a long
show they're watching they're gonna be
mostly watching that yeah but I still
got like a lot of work to do before I
can wrap up my workday
make a sandwich you gonna go make a
sandwich you mix sounds you gonna make
me do you want a sandwich yeah how many
sounds yeah all right cool all right so
uh have a good rest of your day we'll
talk to you guys again tomorrow
like share subscribe yeah there you go